to stop a nosebleed pinch the bridge of
your nose and tilt your head back
that's the exact opposite of what you
should do it's okay to use
q-tips to clean your ears oh boy
taping your mouth shut will stop your
story okay
this another one i'm ripping up never
tape your mouth shut
so i'm dr eric voigt i'm an
otolaryngologist head and neck surgeon
i'm an associate professor of
otolaryngology at nyu langone health
i've been in practice for over 20 years
and i am dr jackie jones i'm an
associate professor
of otolaryngology at weill cornell
medicine
and i've been in practice for almost 31
years now we are
specialists in ear nose and throat so
our field
actually the real title is oto rhino
laryngology odo's ear
rhino his nose larynx is laryngology so
we sort of think of it as one continuous
passage from your nose
down into your lungs so everything is
interconnected
and today we will be debunking myths of
the ear nose and throat
it's okay to hold in your sneeze
not a good idea i think a small sneeze
can be held in but if you're generating
one of those big sneezes
you don't want to hold it in all of that
pressure is going to back up into your
ears
into your throat into your lungs our
nose is the filter
of everything we're breathing in so
you're breathing in pollen you're
breathing in germs you're breathing in
particles and dust
that builds up in our mucus and then a
sneeze is the reflex to
get that material out but sneezing is
overall a good thing because you are
clearing out your nose but again
cover up cover up it's okay to use
q-tips to clean your ears
oh boy oh boy so this
is a box of cotton tip applicators and
there is a warning on here but
whoa eric i don't think i can see this i
brought a magnifying glass just to
demonstrate
there is a warning label on there and it
says and i quote do not insert swab into
ear canal
but see how small that is it really
should be in big bold letters here but
we're telling you
don't do it so this is a plastic model
of an ear
this is called the pinna and this is the
outer ear and you can use a cotton tip
applicator
to clean the outside the little grooves
you can see some people do have
as their wax is coming out they can
clean that outer portion
that's okay but you do not want to go
putting this in here like this
because you're going to push your wax in
you're going to braid the surfaces and
you're going to cause damage
some of the things that i recommend on
cleaning the ear is
drop some alcohol in the ear and again
as long as you don't have any ear
problems or hole in your ear
you can use hydrogen peroxide that tends
to bubble a bit but can be used
and a warm wet washcloth that you wring
out well and use to clean the outside of
your ear we really don't want you to
over clean your ear
bugs can't get inside your ears oh gross
get those mattresses off the floor
because no matter how clean you are
those bugs could climb into your bed
first of all bugs don't want to be in
your ear they're they are actually
afraid of us
they they're private so cockroaches
spiders they don't want but every once
in a while they'll
meander in and the ear is a blind pouch
i've seen actually a spider with who's
made a web
inside of someone's ear canal and the
thing about the cockroach is
they go in but they can't turn around
once they're in there there's not enough
space for them to turn around and get
out
so what they do is they keep clawing
forward against the eardrum and
i don't know if you've ever seen
cockroaches legs under a microscope but
it's like the hairs and
their hooks and so then they're
scratching the eardrum
and as they're scratching the eardrum
the sound that's generated is horrendous
and the pain is generated as horrendous
so the person starts scratching at their
ear and
their ear starts bleeding i've seen
people come into that er
ripping their ear off and so i
immediately know from across the room
cockroach in the ear so what we do is we
try to calm the person down
and then you can put rubbing alcohol in
the ear or mineral oil in the ear
or some liquid that will actually kill
the the bug
and then you can suction it out
cockroaches about the grossest thing
that we see
but you can get flying insects in there
too so same sort of thing we want to
drown them
uh out but you know you don't have to be
phobic it's pretty gross but we don't
see it that frequently but if it happens
to you at home
try not to panic and just put rubbing
alcohol
or mineral oil in your ear and then go
to the doctor stop a nosebleed
pinch the bridge of your nose and tilt
your head back
no no i'm trying this out great i'm so
glad he did this
and this is not an offense to the school
nurse they're
classically told pinch up here and hold
your head back
and that's the exact opposite of what
you should do first off the nose has a
tremendous blood supply the blood supply
to the nose has
five arteries that meet up here in the
front it's called kisselbox plexus
and kistelbox plexus have arteries and
veins that meet together so if you pinch
the front of your nose
the sidewall against the septum and hold
it for five minutes
and they stay upright and lean forward a
little bit so that you can if some of
the blood's going down the back you can
spit it out
but if you pinch your nose for five
minutes you will stop
ninety percent of nosebleeds absolutely
think of it as if you had a cut on
your skin you see the blood what do you
do you put
pressure on it pressure stops bleeding
because it allows
the flow to stop and then your own
clotting mechanism to kick in
taping your mouth shut will stop your
story okay
this another one i'm ripping up never
tape your mouth shut
i don't know how that's out there
because when you're asleep you need to
breathe
and let's just say your nose gets
blocked and congested and you've got
your mouth tape shut
how are you breathing so never snoring
comes from many different places you're
not just snoring from your mouth
snoring comes from the turbulent flow of
air through the respiratory system
and that turbulent flow can come from
your nose it can come from your mouth
you can come from lower down in your
throat so just taping your mouth closed
is not going to fix that problem for a
lot of people it's very dangerous yeah
and very dangerous
not recommended only loud music causes
hearing loss
okay only loud music how about anything
loud
can cause hearing loss there's different
ways your ear can get damaged one is a
sudden loud noise blast so let's say
a firearm or a firework near the ear
then
there's a cumulative effect where you
might have noise that's say
90 decibels or 100 decibels over time
that also will start harming those cells
so i'm speaking about 35 to 40 decibels
right now
so 80 to 90 decibels is pretty loud the
more worrisome loss is that cumulative
loss because people don't even realize
it's happening
you know you go on the subways you walk
around in the city
it can be really loud the construction
sounds factory noises
sirens all of those things can cause
hearing loss so i think of loud
noise as if you're looking up into the
sun you don't do it right
it hurts same thing loud noise blasting
in your ear
it harms those little inner hair cells
and causes permanent hearing loss
and that's such a great point once it's
gone it's gone
we cannot do really anything to get your
hearing back
once it's gone so thinking about your
hearing early on in life
is an important factor swimming causes
ear infections
all right well many people swim
it's a very common human activity not
everybody gets an ear infection
but there is an entity called swimmer's
ear swimmer's ear
is when you get an overgrowth of either
bacteria
or fungus in the outside ear canal one
of the main
culprits from swimmers ear is over
cleaning of your ear when you look at
the ear canal
this is the outer ear your ear canal is
about an inch and a half long
it's lined with wax glands these glands
produce
cerumen or wax that waterproof our ear
that's one of the jobs that's why it's
waxy so when people
clean out their ear too much they're
taking all the wax away
now water's going in and when water is
sitting on the skin
in a dark cave the skin if you've ever
had you know taken a long bath and your
skin kind of changes a little bit or
you've had your
foot in water for a long time it changes
it so that change occurs in the ear and
all of a sudden this ear canal
is going to start collapsing and closing
and
closing and closing and the germs inside
start multiplying and then you get
swimmer's ear which is an
outer ear infection these are some of
the most painful infections
that we've seen and what's another big
culprit
for swimmers here is these things that i
absolutely love
but they're not great especially in the
summer i think we have to make a new
name
your buddy you're putting this thing in
your ear and what's the thing that it's
doing in the summer it's making
warm dark environment even warmer and
darker so some things you can do to
treat it at home or even preventative if
you swim a lot
you can use rubbing alcohol you just get
an ear dropper
and you can put three drops or so in
your ear wiggle it around
let it drain out you can also use
vinegar
cut it half with water you can put that
in your ear as well
after swimming or if you feel water
stuck in your ears you should always get
rid of earwax
you should not get rid of your wax
earwax is protection to your ear now
there are circumstances where we as ear
nose and throat doctors do take out the
ear wax
but that's when there's too much of it
so in a doctor's office you might use an
ear curette as the doctor will go
in and pull the wax out but this is done
under a microscopic guidance and
incredibly gently because if you go too
far in
you're going to burst the eardrum or
you're going to scratch the ear and it's
going to bleed
yeah and one of the things that we use
in the office to protect the outside ear
canal
is we use a speculum which we put it in
the outside portion of the ear canal and
then we work
through this little speculum to sort of
protect the ear canal
so these are things you just can't do at
home
loss of smell is only temporary well
that's a big one this year yeah
you know as we've gone through covid one
of the big warning signs
of kova 19 was loss of sense of smell
and and taste associated with what
happened is the virus goes
into the nose and it hits those
olfactory nerves which are the nerves
that supply the sense of smell to our
brain and the olfactory nerve sits
way back here in the back of the nose
so it's a really interesting place you
only really smell from this
back of the nose the sense of smell is
probably the least appreciated of our
senses
but when you lose it it's devastating so
some of those causes can be
a head injury so our brain sits here
this is the bottom of the skull
and there are these little teeny tiny
openings teeny tiny openings where
the hair cells of the olfactory nerve go
through
and enter into the nose so if you get a
whiplash injury
your head goes like this those little
hair cells can get
sheared and you can have a permanent
loss of sense of smell simply from
a whiplash injury or a head injury some
of these are
permanent some are temporary so one of
the things big things that we've been
working on this year is olfactory
training
for people who've lost their sense of
smell from cover 19
where those nerves have been damaged
what we do is we have
you get different types of smells we use
essential oils and
lavender eucalyptus cinnamon lemon are
some of my favorites
and then what you do is you use those
every day and what it does it helps to
retrain your brain to recognize those
smells
headphones are just as bad as earbuds
for your hearing
so there are in the ear earbuds okay i
think we have an example i
do i brought mine when this goes in your
ear for some people if they're the type
of person that makes a lot of ear wax
they might be shoving their wax in so if
you pull your earbud out and you see a
big glob of wax
you might have a big accumulation inside
and that's why you're not hearing so
well
in addition the earbuds sitting in there
for long periods of time can start
hurting your ear the ear is a dark moist
environment you can start getting ear
infections from them
the pressure of the plastic could press
on the tmj or your jaw joint causing
pain in your ear
so those are some of the drawbacks but
they do provide a nice
sound quality but i try and limit myself
to use them maybe an
hour to a day at the most when i'm
commuting back and forth to work
one of the things that as ear nose and
throat doctors that we like better
is over-the-ear earphones so these have
some real advantages
they're much more comfortable they
dissipate the sound so it's not that
concentrated sound down into your ear
canal
they're not going to push that wax down
into your ears so
a much better choice is these
over-the-ear earphones
so these are the noise canceling ones
what are your thoughts about these yeah
so noise canceling
has a few advantages it can block out
the outside noise
so then you don't have to blast your
music over the outside noise
we don't like any blasting of noise
whether it be over the ear or in the ear
just don't do it it's just unhealthy for
your ears
if you have pain in your ear you have an
ear infection as an ear nose and throat
doctor
i probably see more non-ear related ear
pain or
ear caused ear pain than ear infection
ear pain
and the reason for that is the ear has
five
nerves that innervate it for sense
and those nerves can give what's called
referred pain from other sites
someone might come in and say they have
an ear infection because they have ear
pain but i'll examine them and their ear
is fine
but where the sight of the infection is
is their jaw joint
they may have had a tooth extracted two
weeks ago and the dentist was pulling
their jaw
they might have muscle tension people
might grind their teeth
so all of those are very common causes
of ear pain and that's not from an ear
infection yeah and that's a really good
point because referred pain can be from
anywhere it can be from the throat from
deeper down
another big source of ear pain is
eustachian two problems and that's
that drainage passage that runs from
the back of the ear into the nose and
all of us have experience at some point
when you fly
that feeling of pressure and pain in
your ear your hearing's
bad or you know you're having problems
with your sense of smell
your voice is changing don't just ignore
it so if you've got some issues with
your ears your nose your throat your
head and neck if you feel a lump or bump
you've got pain that's not going away
it's probably worthwhile to get a
checkup
don't ignore symptoms that are lingering
for more than two weeks
because there could be something serious
going on